we're gonna start breaking this down
from npr justice ruth bader ginsburg
champion of gender equality dies at 87.
i'm going to show you her uh one of her
her i'm gonna show you her dying wish
that npr is included that i
was shocked to hear according to npr
they say just days before her death as
her strength waned
ginsburg dictated this statement to her
granddaughter clara spara
quote my most fervent wish is that i
will not be replaced until a new
president is installed
okay that is shockingly 2020
and uh uh we're we're we're going to
start getting into
we're going to lighten up in a little
bit i want to make sure we're being
respectful and delicate as we talk about
her losing her life for sure
but we're going to uh lighten up and
talk about the future in a second but i
just want to say
i'm that that quote to me is
uh it's bordering on the absurd i i
can't
it's it's almost shocking that they
that's the statement that was put out
but let me just read a little bit they
say justice ruth bader ginsburg the
demure firebrand
who in her 80s became a legal cultural
and feminist icon has died
the supreme court announced her death
saying the cause was complications from
cancer
architect of the legal fight for women's
rights in the 1970s ginsburg
subsequently served 27 years
on the nation's highest court becoming
its most prominent member
her death will inevitably set in motion
what promises to be a nasty
and tumultuous political battle over who
will succeed her
and it thrusts the supreme court vacancy
into the spotlight of the presidential
campaign
she knew what was to come ginsburg death
ginsburg's death will have a prof will
have profound consequences for the
country for the court
and the country inside the court not
only is the leader of the liberal wing
gone
but with the court about to open a new
term chief justice john roberts no
longer holds the controlling vote
in closely contested cases though he has
consistently conservative
though he has a consistently
conservative record on most cases he has
split from fellow conservatives
and a few important ones this year
casting his vote with liberals for
instance
to it uh to at least temporarily protect
the so-called dreamers from deportation
by the trump administration to uphold a
major abortion precedent
and to uphold bans on large church
gatherings during the chronovirus
pandemic
but with ginsburg gone there is no clear
court majority
for those outcomes now the most
important thing that needs to be
mentioned as we enter an election cycle
that will likely be disputed
is that the supreme court now skews
conservative
very likely meaning if this if if
if we go to a contested election and the
court must decide
i think they're going to side with trump
well
i'm i'm a bit i'm a bit look we we got
50 billion stories here we've got who's
trump going to pick amy coney barrett
conservative what will the left's
reaction be
let me just ask you right away uh just
off of your general your general
reaction both you guys
let's just get into it yeah i mean first
and foremost obviously you the prayers
are with her family
and the repose of her soul and you know
she'd be bad on cancer for a long time
and
i think npr hit the nail on the head and
they talked about her being a cultural
icon
right i i don't think i'm gonna blow
anyone's mind when i say that i don't
necessarily agree with the sorts of
things she stood for to be a cultural
icon but i think it's important to
recognize that she is
and i mean i think this is you know we
chat about a little bit before the show
but this is going to be an enormous gut
punch
to millions and millions of people
across the country and i think for a lot
of people that will be the cultural
and you know cultural import but tim i
think you're right i think one of the
biggest things that might get overlooked
here is
if there are people who don't believe in
the integrity of the supreme court as a
result of her leaving which i think a
lot of people wrongfully will
we're gonna have to deal with that on
election day careful
pounding sorry yeah yeah so uh
it's not just that they would side with
trump if it goes
if if the vote gets contested we're
looking at a mailing we're looking at
mail-in ballots
i've talked to my progressive friends
they think it's totally safe and they
don't know anything about the stories
that have emerged like in in paterson
new jersey for instance they voided
the election there's something like a
million primary ballots have been
discounted or relate the new york times
reported this
uh in baltimore i think it was 68 000
ballots were held for five days
but the puzzle service wasn't delivering
them there have been numerous errors
and now they might side with donald
trump the court
however the left might view it as
illegitimate yep but the court's missing
the key vote
right how can it and what if they split
what if it goes four four if it goes
four four i mean what do you do man
dude and i mean i think we you know you
can come into it to the election and say
hey even if you
even if you're someone who is worried
about it then at least we've got the
supreme court to be able to moderate
this thing and now
we don't know that we'll have the
numbers and if we do have the numbers
you're right i mean think about it like
we we saw how upset people were in 2016.
and now imagine all of those people not
only are upset
but they're also thinking that the
results of the election are illegitimate
and that they're not fair and that of
course it's donald trump's fault
and then so so the election breaks
mainland voting is contested on both
sides
on election day donald trump landslides
it's called the red mirage
republicans are going to go vote go vote
in person democrats vote by mail
that means on election night trump wins
in a landslide over the next several
days the democrat votes start pouring in
and then it flips to joe biden donald
trump then starts contesting some of
these mail-in votes saying some were
discounted some were counted that
shouldn't have been those voters
those signatures don't match you know we
saw in pennsylvania they ruled
signature verification out the window
right they now can't disqualify a vote
if the senior
signature doesn't match arguing they
should be able to give the voter a
chance to fix it so what it takes two
months
to fix all the votes not gonna happen
trump's gonna sue
joe biden's gonna sue it's gonna go to
the supreme court
and what if it goes 4-4 i don't think it
would because they lost
ruth bader ginsburg but roberts
roberts and i think conservatives have
have learned their
lesson time and time again that roberts
is not some sort of stalwart
conservative that we should put our
faith in yeah could you
could you imagine if it finally goes to
the court and they go 4-4 on this
what do you do i don't even know that's
the other thing too is i don't
you would have legal fights about how to
resolve the legal fight the supreme
court is
not in a position to actually solve the
problem with only eight members
trump needs to appoint someone now and
this person needs to be
confirmed now now now now the problem
with that though
is that the left is going to be we we
were talking about the white house siege
right
yeah did you hear about this project oh
yeah so for those that aren't familiar
a group called adbusters the magazine
had put out a call for uh
what it was a 50 days of protest called
the white house siege in front of the
white house
it was supposed to be non-violent but i
guess
nobody was buying it because they called
it a siege so they changed it to 50 days
of improvisational jazz
because they really did not want
violence i can respect that peaceful
protest is cool it's cool sure
but it was announced by the general
assembly the activists in dc
that due to donald trump they would be
canceling the the event
because they felt like free speech free
speech was under attack and all that
stuff
if there was anything that could ignite
a legitimate
50-day siege and i don't mean like jazz
or non-violent protest i mean quite
literally people
shaking the fences they were pounding on
the doors of the supreme court when
brett kavanaugh was getting it was uh
it was the supreme court or what
building was it um i think it was in the
senate the senate yeah
they were trying to get another center
right they were banging on the doors yep
oh here it comes and that and i mean
obviously the kavanaugh appointment was
huge it was historic it was important
but it's
it's it pales in comparison i mean it's
not even close like this is
we've never had something like this in
terms of a supreme court appointment and
so
yeah i think everything's out the window
and on top of that you've got all of
these people be they political or
otherwise who have been cooped up for
six seven eight months oh
man all they want to do is get out of
the house are we in a simulation
you know
if it is it's too much what did you say
the writers of 2020
to put this right before the election
it's like you gotta you gotta reign in
the audience a little bit more right
we've got we've got the election coming
up we're not even into december if
you're going to throw something that big
out
already knowing you've got a planned
election coming up in one of your
episodes in the future
the writers are ham-fisted at this point
no no i kind of feel like it's a it's
game of thrones early season worthy
where like you're watching and also and
you're like no way they just killed oh
how did they kill that red wedding yeah
yeah the red wedding they killed
everyone this is our red wedding but
but i mean at least well the democrats
are saying that oh god seriously but you
can at least you can put the book down
you can turn the tv off this is life i
mean
i'm i'm gonna go back to i'm gonna go
back to my apartment in dc and it's
gonna be
it's gonna be it's gonna be protests
it's gonna be court you know cordoned
off
city streets it's you know and i really
wanna stress
uh i know there's a lot of partisan
people npr says it's going to get nasty
i have tremendous respect for ruth bader
ginsburg man i really do she she battled
that cancer like one of the strongest
one of the strongest people uh i've ever
seen suffering from you know
the illness and she kept she kept
winning and she and she she
she uh she uh with stood it for as long
as she possibly could and it was
impressive it was remarkably impressive
and i think she had pneumonia too
yeah at some point yeah she was
hospitalized i think once maybe a couple
of times
i was impressed with the sheer willpower
and as much as like you mentioned
you know look we don't have to agree
with her politically in fact we can very
much disagree and be worried about her
politics
but uh i i think you know look we we are
americans first and foremost
and that sheer willpower to try and
stand throughout the election was
impressive
uh you know i know a lot of people are
probably happy that trump will not get
to make an appointment but i hope people
recognize
we can be you know sad to see her go and
prayers and respect to her family and
all that while still being like
okay you know without reveling in that
you know we're looking to the future and
and what's going to come next and uh
already we're seeing
uh a lot of photos popping up of who
comes next yeah so first and foremost
let me see uh we have uh this photo
right here from
uh cassandra fairbanks tweeted just this
photo and uh we all know what it is it's
it's amy coney barrett
so uh i believe trump will appoint her
we can also see this
take a look right here trending politics
2.69 million tweets
no no no
we got to be we got to be careful
because we are going to have a lot of
laughter going on here at the expense of
many of the people on the left
yes and i want to you know just say it's
like you know
it's not at the expense of ruth bader
ginsburg in any capacity
but uh seeing the reaction now nearly
what 2.7 million tweets of no no no
what did you just say it was like it's
like hillary clinton hillary clinton
election night yeah
it's going to be that times a thousand
right it's it's gonna be the
i'm sure you all remember that image of
the the individual wailing at the sky
right that was the inauguration i think
it was yeah yeah or was it i thought it
was when they called the election was it
but i could be right
i could be wrong but it's it's going to
be that and i mean you know
we were talking before like it's it
feels almost a little bit crass to have
to dive into what the political
implications of this are
but the political implications are
enormous you can't escape them
especially with especially with what 46
days to the election who did who did
trump
uh trump chose a handful of people for
his new list and he included dude
i know he chose tom cotton because i'm
gonna mention his quote in a second yeah
but you know who some of the other
picks were yeah so comey barrett i think
was on the list
mike lee from utah i believe is on the
list there's one
other senator i think as well it was
yeah
it was secretaries who like in his own
respect is a pretty impressive
constitutional law scholar by all
indications and so like these are
it's complicated because they're
political right but they're they're
people with serious
at least legal bona fides of not
judicial bona fides um and then there
are a number of other people on there
who i think are circuit court judges
um and then there are a few i think
there's a big push among a lot of
conservative legal advocates who were
fighting for clarence thomas clerks
right people like there was a big push
um after especially after
you know gorsuch i think had made a
couple of decisions that folks didn't
like kavanaugh's made a couple decisions
people didn't like and so there's been a
big push by a lot of
a lot of the legal talking heads in dc
to say you know what the only one we can
trust is clarence thomas and the only
people we should be putting on this list
are people who have clerked for him well
so uh a lot of people think he's gonna
choose
uh amy coney barrett and i think
i i would i would have to say so now
before we get into it we can actually
pull up
some information about her because again
people think it will be her
he selected one of the people on his
short list was tom cotton
and then he and then you we saw i think
some of these other people
said i appreciate it i have no interest
in leaving the senate
josh josh and uh and ted and tom cotton
said
that what did you say the days of roe v
wade are numbered yeah exactly it's like
well the days of roe v wage should be
over and i would be
he also said i would be honored to serve
my country and he's like
someone who has served their country for
a long time i would be honored to serve
my country in any capacity
if he's gunning he's gunning if trump
picks tom cotton
after tom cotton said that it is going
to be
war in dc like you you you i'm
we've talked about conflict before we've
talked about civil unrest
but tom cotton straight up said it days
of roe v wade
are numbered or something to that effect
yeah if if trump says
yeah tom cotton and they and they say
he's moving forward
and they set up a senate confirmation
within a month of the election
it is going to be it's impossible to
overstate what that would look like i
know i don't even i don't
i'm scared to say what i think it would
result in and don't forget
tom cotton is persona non grata enough
to the left that when he wrote an op-ed
voicing an opinion that is shared by
almost 60 percent of americans
you had the guy who runs the op-ed page
resign
and you had a you had a staff revolt
yeah you had a staff revolt
not just at the new york times but
everywhere there were other people who
backed him up who lost their jobs right
it's it rolled journalism and in the
same way that was over an op-ed
take a look at this from the hill tom
cotton after trump names him potential
supreme court nominee quote it's time
for roe v
wade to go 100 i'm estimating but it's
100
i'm rounding up 110 000 shares on the
hill from september 9th
i i gotta say man when you make a joke
about this the 2020 season writers
you mean to tell me that donald trump
put out a list a week ago
where the guy said roe v weighs out ruth
bader ginsburg dies a week later
if he picks this dude and the supreme
court is split four to four with with
robert sitting with the liberals against
trump and there's no clear winner and
no way to resolve this yeah this is an
existential crisis for this country man
and this is an existential crisis if
everything goes well between now and
then
right i think one of the things that
unfortunately we haven't always done a
great job of in 2020 is
recognizing that it always gets worse
right it only like it only gets worse
and deeper in ways we don't understand
or expect
what if coronavirus comes back worse
winter what if what if what a flu season
makes sense there's so much
dude the aliens are coming the ship's
going to land in a week and we're gonna
be like thank you
as a dc resident um if tom cotton and
dobby wrong i love tom cotton huge tom
cotton fan
i've been boosting him for a long time
if he gets nominated to the supreme
court in the protest start i think i'm
rooting for
for aliens to show up i think that i
think that would probably make my
day-to-day life a lot easier
let me tell you dude uh a while a while
ago
or beginning of the year i started
looking at properties far away from
cities
and i found one and it was very very
difficult to set up and buy
and we're officially set up uh as soon
as we wrap up this show we're hopping in
a car driving for several hours
and i'm gonna wake up at the new
facility we're gonna start setting up
the new studio because i do not want to
be anywhere
near these cities and after look we can
talk about antifa we can talk about the
proud boys and
i lived in new york people were planting
bombs like there was just crazy people
so i wanted to get away from these
cities as the political tensions flared
up but this
is the sharpest spike in emotional shock
we have seen in the entire year yeah
like everybody knew it was coming it was
a
it was a time bomb and now it's dropped
and it dropped a week after tr
tom cotton said wow man i'm telling you
if you were if you were writing 2020 as
a show and all you were trying to do
is freak your your show watchers out
that's what you do i mean i don't know
what you would do different
and one of the one of the other problems
with the two is it comes at a time when
people are already emotionally frayed
everyone is burnt out everyone is worn
down they're worn down by politics
they're worn down
by coronavirus they're worn down by the
lockdown and everything else we're
swirling around it and now you throw
this into the mix
i gotta say i'm kind of freaking out man
yeah me too
this is this was like so uh uh for those
that are listening we
we we're sitting here at like a gatorade
and we were like making jokes and i was
like i think we're going to talk about
you know there's this thing with joe
rogan that's really interesting
and then all of a sudden i see the tweet
breaking it was what
here's what you did so you open up
twitter and you're like all right so
what are we going to talk about
and you were like oh i felt like it was
the car no i think i said
oh my god oh my god oh my god i put my
hands on my head and i was like oh my
god
and then and then lydia's like what what
happened and i was like ruth bader
ginsburg died
and i was like oh this is my god this is
crazy and you started it by saying
what's the biggest story of the day and
we were like
we're like kicking around our heads
you're like i don't know man i mean it's
broken things big like there's
there's a few other things going on i
think oh is it chris rock said something
like that was the kind of news we were
kicking around
and said chris ross said this is a big
big news and you yeah hands on the head
and you were like
i was it was like a former oc actress
from that tv show
came out in support of trump right which
is cool and i was like we're gonna have
a fun conversation about like walk away
and like never trumper and stuff and uh
but here check this out this is what
this is what's happened so over on
twitter we have the trending tab
number one is rip ruth bader ginsburg
with with absolute respect number two is
ruth bader ginsburg nearly 500
000 tweets followed by supreme court
mcconnell
notorious rbg rest in power rest in
peace rbg
not rbg rip rbg rip ruth kavanaugh
and then puerto rico which is still big
news and then it goes to rosh hashanah
and a bunch of other things but then it
goes back to murkowski
like anyway the point is look tom
cotton's trending roe v wade is trending
no no no with with now nearly three
million tweets is trending amy coney
barrett trending moscow mitch rb
the entire trending tab up 29
trends save for like four things are
uh well first of all it's all politics
except for rosh hashanah
and then everything else is political
puerto rico is not related to supreme
court so it's like
27 of 30 trends are all the supreme
court
this is the most uh significant
political development of the year i'd
say right
it it has to be and think about how
insane that is of trump's
yeah think about how insane that is that
this that that we
up until 45 minutes ago we had not seen
the most insane
political story we're going to see this
year yeah that's funny to me because we
were just kind of lamenting how crazy
this year had been
yeah oh my gosh this lockdown this crazy
stuff if i could go back in time and
tell myself you know
coronavirus is it is what it is i mean
we have the
idea the great the great triggering is
upon us yeah the no
no no twitter trend three million people
saying no no no and they're posting
memes of like
you know a guy wincing wearing a trump
hat like oh no trump's going to do it
he's going to nominate somebody of
course he is but he has he has to
yes and that's the other thing too is i
think if if it were more normal
times right and potentially with a more
normal president i think what we would
all be saying
right left center is oh god we can't
we can't go into this election without a
full supreme court we have to have
an odd number of people to make whatever
decisions come up we have
50 different state elections that could
all potentially go to the supreme court
we can't do that short staffed thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time
you